should be live
here happy
Monday we're going to be answering some
Discord stuff then we're going to be
reviewing some contributor code live on
stream and then I'll see what I do from
there kind of a slow
Monday kind of a slow Monday for me h
though been trying to put more time into
the uh the promo on X it's been going
decent but I do need to get back to
doing doing some
code all right I created a gym and how
do I W wrap this with puffer to
vectorize callables
of
callables extreme selection
and is your environment
started
order in increasing perf
order you can use r
native vectorized AP I
we light boost curently bit
harder could
go got to be providing quality user
support here quality user support
do well this this one's a new M we don't
even have like an existing
all right let's see we had a couple
other ones that
um we had a couple other ones to review
as well and then two PRS is the main
thing also happy to get people on
boarded to puffer if you're interested
in contributing stuff happy to do that
now as
well where did this go somebody was
asking about like an M that wasn't
training well with Puffer
well I'm not seeing it here he'll uh
he'll post again after he makes some
progress I'm
the the two PRS going we have
Connect Four fixes and I think go as
solid well I'm sure that they're PR
anyway so let's go check them on the
perfect so some substantial changes to
connect for
here uh I'm going to
right I think um since Jake is not
around in person for this I will have
this recording but also so he doesn't
have to like watch back a recording I'll
just start a proper review
changes I swear did the UI for this [ __ ]
get
worse oh no you have yeah you can come
in at each spot perfect so we'll just do
that we got P0 P1 okay some minor stuff
up
top player pieces M
pieces position mask okay he renamed
some
stuff probably cuz he wanted to make
mask a
function create a pieace
bit string ones are not redundant I mean
the bit mask ones are not
redundant we change valid move to
invalid move maybe this was just
mask or
wait what the heck is
redundant let me
just yeah one of the great things for
chat jippy is making sure I'm not
actually insane
correct yeah I prefer these not being
onlined I've gone back and forth on this
one a bunch but I do think it's actually
substantially better to not on
line diagonal
di okay both diagonals cool vertical
turn false okay this is
clean
um what on
Earth an algorithm I haven't heard of
before
variant
form relies on Zero
okay I'm not going to attempt to
understand algorithm at this point but
sure
[Music]
okay uh I can't actually
tell wait
this is bizarre logic
right yeah this is
bizarre we got to
out I think what I'm going to do is
unless Jake shows up I'm going to leave
all these comments for
um you
know purposes of giving feedback on
stuff but then I'm just going to do the
merge myself so I don't just like you
know be nitpicking stuff and delaying
things you know I'll just do it and I'll
make the fixes unless he shows
up break ties oh I should also Post in
the
Discord that I am live here
compute and
move so yeah this function is redundant
what oh I see what he means
by this isn't really a hash
this okay so here's the core
algorithm there's like some minor
spacing stuff I'm not going to nitpick
it's mostly preference
anyways this looks
like I might have to look at the tie
breaking in
this there might have to be something
with breaking
skip the Sentinel
row
okay it's
fine I think the most useful thing for
Jake here is going to just to be when I
merge this to have my diff on
this so he'll get to review my review
and if I inevitably break it in the
process then well bad on
move I think he's missing a log
here might be missing a log here for
um oh M action just means opponent AI
action okay this is fine I'd probably
space this stuff a little differently
the code is good though it's like minor
minor
minor I actually haven't figured out how
I like to space stuff fully MC yet um I
definitely don't want to
add okay there is no lank line between
these
good now I haven't figured out entirely
it's a little
weird in Python right you have like the
space after the death is your line space
but the with the brace you get tempted
to add yet another space I don't
know that's being Uber pedantic though
the stuff I already covered was more uh
important already this is very clean
though this is like you know 9 and a
half out of 10
clean I'm mainly just looking for things
to nitpick you know to give some amount
of useful
feedback yeah so there's a two-d do here
that just didn't get done that's
fine do
add client stuff in
this yeah okay so we didn't change
client stuff so there's nothing to
review here this is mostly reasonable I
think I actually messed with the I think
I actually messed with this for loading
the textures
anyways rename some
stuff uh set this to
zero and we're good for
in I didn't check that you ped it to the
right branch that was risky
I should be doing that to make sure
people don't actually accidentally PR to
main that'd be
bad let's actually uh fix this stuff
right and let's test his
ran a pretty hard Half Marathon
yesterday and it just like wiped
me it's annoying couple months ago I
wouldn't even be breaking a sweat with
that
uh I think even before we mess with
this let's see a let's see speed test
I keep forgetting to commit the fast
mode for the uh compilation
right want to get involved and
contribute any recommendations on where
we can get involved if we're familiar
with RL but not too familiar with all
the existing environments and tasks uh
it depends on what side that you want to
contribute on a lot of the posts I've
made on X are targeted towards like
engineering side people who are trying
to like do something on end side to get
experience with AI so like I give these
people tasks on improving environments
and like seeing how environments have to
be built to make them good work with RL
and then I slowly move people and do
experiments if you have more experiment
side background and you want to help us
with baselines on stuff basically you
just would need to have like a GPU or
whatever they're pretty darn fast you
can help on
that um um there is core stuff as well I
generally Reserve that for people who've
been contributing for a bit just because
there's a little bit more to onboard
there but yeah either M side or
experiment side I'm happy to get you
started just post a little a little
about like what you're interested in
doing and I'll get you something to work
on with
it we definitely appreciate the
help looking to onboard lots of new
people
go I messed this up now maybe both
working
on tools for AI agents for game
QA are you at like are you at uh model
or something curious to make some
experiments for that
specifically yeah I see
so interesting
um probably the best thing you can do
for that
then you answered my question on Discord
thanks a bunch I'll answer questions
live as
well
um regression games okay let me see
it's funny that they're actually a few
there are a few companies doing this
now so here's the deal with uh here's
the deal with companies right if you
want to contribute um like test like
this as uh open source environments for
puffer I will help you with that for
free and I will get you started on that
for free if you want like more detailed
stuff on Clos Source stuff for just your
company then we have extended support
packages but if you are okay with like
making m's on that side um that you know
can be used more broadly for research as
well as for your company then I can get
you started on that does that sound good
cuz I've got some pretty good ideas of
how you would do this stuff
um there's some like really good stuff
you can do with this that will I think
would help your text stack tremendously
the initial thing I'll tell you with
this is um what I would suggest that you
do
is you make like a representative sample
game that
has either that has some bugs or that
you know you think will probably have
some bugs
you make it as an ultra high performance
environment and then you use this as a
test case for your own tools and your
own methods so that you essentially you
have a very very fast way of trying out
new methods and stuff um that you can
then use those methods on slower m in
your plugins in whatever that's the way
I would go about
it yeah that's what I was thinking yep
so again it's like if you want that test
M to be public and open source I'll help
you with it completely no
charges uh if you want that to be an
internal thing then you're going to get
more minimal support on that
right open source name of the game
here explore some reward functions that
gear towards exploration and Bug finding
versus winning yeah and you can
absolutely do that and uh puffer is a
really good spot to do that in because
the focus on performance means that
you're going to be able to get tens of
billions of samples per GPU per day on
your test M so basically that will allow
you to automate all of your methods
exploration right so whatever ideas you
might have for your main thing right for
your main Tech you'll be able to try
that out Ultra Ultra fast and Puffer
I'll show you how some of our M's are
actually I just reviewed this connect 4M
um so here's Connect 4 in with like a
nice scripted opponent in how long is
this 350 lines of C we've got more
substantial ones as
well we got a g
so this MOA here which has some like
very basic agents running live this is
like 2000ish
lines um so it really doesn't take a ton
in order to get a fairly
sophisticated like game Prototype
thing for what you're interested
in cool thing about running on running
them on web is you can show um you can
put demos right online right
sounds good I'll check it out were you
in Cale don't think we overlapped met
some others from there yeah I was uh I
just graduated this past
spring check out existing M see if I
have ideas yeah there's there are a lot
of them it's they're all in Dev um
environments SL ocean Ocean's first
party I was in Boston for uh a fair bit
I mean I was mostly just there like
working on stuff I didn't do a ton of
you know events and stuff around campus
so also was like traveling a bunch
between
stuff ipri in 2019 19 okay yeah let me
know how that
goes aggression looks cool QA is
definitely a spot for uh definitely a
spot for RL in
games I think you're also going to see
uh you know NPC Ai and stuff like that
for sure lots of nice applications and
games originally I was going to make
puffer a company just for games um but
ultimately I decided that I wanted it to
be broader and I really wanted it to
just be General purpose RL tools for
advancing the space and then provide
stuff to all the different people that
are building specifically for individual
domains
is that's
acceptable got to head out send messages
in Discord as I have questions yeah
Discord or streams I try to answer just
at me if I miss something right I try to
answer either on stream or Discord just
about everything see you around thanks
for dropping
right I think that's probably good
enough we'll see see how it uh how it
holds
up I think it'll be like a bit shy of a
see let's go pull up that uh that review
that I just
is I'm going to just go make all the
changes that I
suggested got a new M now looking
looking to call
emulated from my custom
en do I have to wrap my gymnasium end
with emulation yes if you're not using
our native API then you have to wrap
with emulation what that emulation layer
does is it's going to flatten your
observations it will give you the
ability to unflatten them right before
you need them same with actions this
allows us to do everything faster
there's no loss of generality it's going
to make a couple other optimizations as
well including that like emulation
attribute so it's literally just a
oneline wrapper and uh it keeps
compatibility with gymnasium as two so
gymnasium puffer m is still a gymnasium
M it just has some extra stuff that's
injected into
it that was kind of the secret sauce
that started
puffer not so
secret but hey
should
I did it eat your
message if you have like a python
EnV um that's already a gymnasium en you
may as well just keep it like that for
now try out puffer with our emulation
API a bit and then if you want to go
high perf right the stuff you're seeing
now this is how you go real high perf
and then you go to basically unlimited
data which is pretty cool
okay we're going to
save save a few function calls
should I implement the M using gem or
should I use your native API is there a
simple example like a gymnas like the
gymnasium go left M
um we don't have like trivial examples
for Native API because
like it's there's a little bit of
additional boiler plate that's going to
be required to make stuff really fast
just inherently because like we go from
python to Pyon and optionally to see so
there's going to be binding code across
the across languages right uh we do have
examples our examples are on the level
of we have pong we have like snake we've
got breakout multi-agent single agent
these are like the level of examples
that we have but they all kind of have
the same very simple python binding and
then like essentially a glorified header
file with an extra Loop in it in
scon I think those are probably the best
place to start here let me link them to
you let me link
you cool little company from this guy oh
a16z
guys yeah these are absolutely types of
people I would like to
know I don't know maybe there's some
stuff they will want with
puffer where why am I on
X freaking addictive website when I was
trying to find new code
all right so here is ocean ocean is
first party right and
then something like pong probably is
pretty decently polished so like you can
see pong. pie is just tiny it's
literally just like a
binding and then you got siong this is
your scyon it's a little chunkier but
really it's just like this is a header
file cuz needs
headers and here's just like function
Def and we do this little Shenanigans
here where we run a bunch of
environments uh single thread so that
they run in purec we've got a little
trick for that and then all the core
logic of the game is in thish file which
is 300 lines I will link you
this this is about the level of stuff
you're going to want to be you know
comfortable with if you want to go super
super fast fast with ve uh I mean with
uh with puffer first party
Ms and if anything is confusing there
let me know because I'm trying to make
it easier and
easier C is not required any other fast
low-level language will work we like C
because it compiles nicely to wasum you
could use C++ you could use Zig or
whatever else is
trendy if you want Pure Performance scon
is probably good enough you probably
don't need to go all the way to see it's
just really nice that you can render
stuff on the web cuz you can compile to
web
assembly so we kind of just try to meet
you at whatever level of uh perf you're
willing to you know put the work in to
get we try to like give you the best on
your investment
this is just a mistake right death or
opponent run or yeah this is this is
just a mistake unless I'm really dumb
so this should just be
one other
pieces like this
this and then we'll do this for now and
then we'll see if
logging actually is he missing logs
here
wait we do finish game
game oh no you got it I think he got it
right finish game because the set's
move I got to ask him if this
is reading draws is
losses I I don't want to mess with the
Dynamics though for
uh what I mess up
here right you don't need this
anymore there's no way I made it slower
by doing that there's just no way
me I'm trying to think what the heck I
could have even
done nah that's got to be me running
this on
uh you know on this machine that I'm
using for streaming
happens dude
I I don't know sometimes
that's freaking cursed let me see what
the heck did I even do that could have
changed perf like at
on that's kind of cursed I'm not going
to lie
this extra addition somehow makes it
faster by a
all right so uh very minor edits then in
that
case really didn't change very
section I'm just going to do something
like this
fine I haven't decided whether I like
this or this more and see
think you do this as
well let
whatever I think cuz you don't have dock
strings this is
logs tempted to put this down in the
client code here
member yo I'm available for questions
once you get to go thanks yes Spencer as
soon as I fix this uh connect for
shenanigans
friend what do you rename it
to player pieces
is I thought we got
uh I thought we got changes to this dot
the doci file didn't
something I'm very
[Music]
confused no he did right
here wait position
player
right yeah he just forgot to rename it's
fine
we have a delay here
right yeah so if I do
I think the leaks are in the network
though
right should be done with this in not
very long
okay no errors on perf test interactive
has
some
errors so what do we do here this
is fre
game leaks
are free weights
okay and then those are the normal rid
baks so we are
policy oh that's not bad look at that
200k 1% M
time looks good to
me yeah little policy just small right
small policy
big
small policy big batch can be made faster than this as
batch can be made faster than this as
well I'm
well little
bit all right we'll train uh we'll train
a policy in a bit since uh I think
Spencer is still here we'll Commit This
for now and I'll review as go and then
I'll come back to training
policies let me just uh
do
Jake I think I got the right Jake here
right let me make sure I'm at in the
right Jake
there you
go all right code review for
go go is going to
be a little more
complicated little more
complicated let's see how this is gone
holy all
right okay but this includes everything
so we've got the DOT ining
setup you want me to do a a review in
GitHub as well
Spencer I can do a text review if you
want or I can just do it here up to you
both you cool with just doing it live
yeah sure I'll just do it live if you
prefer I just didn't know if you wanted
to have like comments to look back
through we can just do live
and uh you can either make tweaks or I
can make them I don't care uh let me see
so you added config what's config
say reasonable looking config it's going
to go way faster with more M uh we'll
see whether that destabilizes stuff or
not but it'll go faster once you do
this probably actually won't even need
recurrent with go because it's fully
observed we'll see about that though
um okay added
binding these files are no longer going
to be needed because of uh the new build
ocean
system like you know build web build
local these are just included
now uh I don't see you linking anything
else so we should be good there right
now and can watch VOD again yeah Okay
cool so we'll just do it live then
that'll be easier
anyways like this isn't this ain't no
jira let me make this not be covered by
my
camera there we
go Okay so we've
got scyon bind lot of boiler
plate chunky struck let's
see probably fine gotta be careful with
the action type here potentially if this
isn't handled this can break some stuff
but that's on me not on
you I'm just saying stuff as I see it I
don't I don't care if you forget to like
delete a thing here and there it's I'm
just pointing stuff as I see
it
uh
group oh CU it's a capture group okay
that's
Comey some of the types on these are a
little
interesting last capture
position not sure about all these args
but this is again I need to understand
the Go game better for this uh yeah you
just copied this template perfect got
slicing in here perfect I'm thinking of
changing these from uh ND array CNP ND
array to M map types that might give us
better type checking um but don't worry
about that I'll do it if I need to log
buffer okay you just added everything I
don't know about this last capture
position why this is included maybe
there's a reason for this in
it standard Loop standard step standard
render standard
close we also probably need to call like
I have kind of punted on this we need to
be better about calling the free methods
in scon because this doesn't actually
free everything I don't think we need to
actually call like the free go method or
whatever no big deal for now
we have ways of doing that as well that
are like
cooler there's a cool way that you can
allocate like all the memory for an EnV
such that you can just call free on the
struct and uh it'll free like all the
intermediate buffers as well been
thinking about using that
file okay no policy integrated yet but
you
added you you added some extra Logic for
a mouse input for user Yep this is the
correct place to put it good job there
looks
good I'll get to the big one in a
second GOP should just be small
right yeah pretty much just exactly as
uh we had it before you added the setup
and we're good all right so the main
thing is
go.
okay so all this code is getting PR at
once right which means I can actually
just view
perfect convention but I usually like to
put the uh the non-standard libraries at
the bottom and also add a
space okay you got your
defines are
good
directions yep preallocated
good I actually don't know why I've been
using pound defines for everything
instead of
consts um
I don't know we'll see about that this
is
copied right yeah this is just you added
a couple things to it game is played but
this is
group this is what they're called in go
right
generic name but I think this is what
they're called in go it's fine int
parent what the
oh did you reinvent a linked list let me
think let's see what you did
[Music]
um you kind of reinvented Link list but
it's actually kind of
fine yeah fine with this you reinvented
um o actually wait does this work I'm
going to have to see how this works like
how you if you have to like update
parents and
stuff cuz you did reinvent a link list
but depending this could just be
what does it mean to
find the start of a
group I don't know what it means to find
the start of a group because this is
like this recursive thing right this is
like this uh recursive
thing so I don't know what it means to
find the start of a
return if the group
rank is less than the other group
rank then you
reparent add the
size and you add the liberties
get the parent and the Liberties at any
spot it's just to track one node that
keeps track of a state or
group
um
oh is it o of
one is this not like a recursive thing
where you have to keep going like find
do find do find you
know is this like just like a
everything's parented to is this like a
maximum depth 2 thing or like Max death
one
like everything in group one that would
have to get reparented to pause two
would
it so how's this all1
welcome YouTube folks we're reviewing
this PR of this go
environment really solid looking
environment just going to go through and
make sure everything is set this is by
Spencer who you can see up
here yeah I see see the size and
Liberties this like this I understand I
just don't understand how the
reparenting thing works if this is
supposed to be o of one it seems like
you have to keep going up a chain to
find the the start of the
group we need a drawing board can you
see this message now yeah I see your
message oh yeah I guess X was eating
your
messages yeah X and YouTube like to eat
messages when you type a
lot twitch does not
I don't know I would what I would be
drawing quite yet
Splinter it's O of group
size based on where you are in the chain
but not very
big all right if we needed to go faster
this is a place that I would
look
um potentially this is a place I would
look cuz it's also like extra recursive
function calls on top of that but uh
I'll take your word on that for now cuz
otherwise outside of that this is
cool then you you've got your main go
data
structure generate board
positions wait
what grid Square
size grid Square
size grid
size
uh what
I'm kind of surprised that you need to
do this for the render render should be
plenty fast either way but sure
whatever in it groups
yeah okay good you found out how uh how
nice 1D traversal is because you can
just do I without doing the extra
indexing you just do it once up here
this is
good then you init
lots of C
then there's allocate which is fine this
is all fine
yep and compute
observations you did you're still doing
the Stacked thing right so we'll have to
do an experiment oblation on this to see
if this actually
matters um but yeah fine if you're going
to do
stacked then this is
reasonable I see why this works do
people actually do this wait isn't this
off by
one hold on Buddy isn't this off
wait [ __ ] isn't
one does doesn't this evaluate to one on
the first
loop I think it starts at
zero then should be the last
position uh I don't know I think that
this could be we should check this I
think this is a possible off by one
there could be some Bizarro thing where
like this Plus+ is a like does it and
then evaluates and like plus plus OBS
index would be off by one um it's been a
long time since I've seen something like
that but I think this is off by one I
don't know if you if you're in chat and
you know feel free to comment if this is
off by one but
uh yeah
oh and then you also put the score at
the end which is
interesting
okay if you're looking for easy wins
here by the way um I believe a mem set
is way faster than this so like anytime
you need to zero something like this if
you really really need to hammer perf
you can just mem set but I expect that
the algorithm side is probably more
expensive we'll see about
that
so out of
bounds you
return okay so you did Flood fill
recursive
um I have like an iterative flood fill
implementation that you might want to
see
we should probably like time some of
these functions I your m is already
pretty damn fast though right we might
want to time some stuff I generally
don't do a ton of recursive stuff um
I'll usually just use arrays and like
stacks and qes for
traversal but if it's already fast
enough then it doesn't really
matter yeah this is
fine okay so I don't know what Trump
Taylor score
is
scoring Trum tail is probably the
bottleneck we should time it instead of
guessing I showed did I show you how to
do
CPR did I show you how to do c profile I
think I did on stream right
perf like lots of small iterative okay
so I'll show you how to do c profile
it's very easy I thought I did but I'll
show you again no worries it's just like
it lets you get function level breakdown
like function level stats on performance
very
quickly so once I once I merge this
we'll do that for you if you're still if
you're still on then I'll do this for
you live so we can decide uh what needs
to be
optimized but okay count Stones Mark is
visited
you cleaned up a bunch of code though
from before this is
good uh
Yu yeah flood fill on the
uh oh but wait are you're only flood
filling the whole board once right it's
that you're calling this from different
positions so this is really this is only
o of board size it probably just has a
big constant on it
it's not as bad as it looks though cuz
you're not flood filling the whole board
right you're only flood filling that
territory so it's still ow of number of
tiles it probably just has a big
obnoxious constant Factor on it and like
I see some stuff where
like yeah like here's
um maybe this check gets repeated a few
times or something
I don't know what minus n Comey is is
this like a
handicap plus
territory there's
territory neutral player okay so you're
just counting this is
fine capture group yep okay you got mem
set here you actually do it here you
free uh wait you have you set visited to
zero properly here but then you have a
function up here reset visited which is
slower
right so yeah you you've got this both
ways and this is the fast one is the mem
set
here oh look you do it you do it well
here though yeah this is what I
suggested right you can do this for
flood fill as well
Legacy code yeah no
worries yeah good this is this is where
you want to be Q size you can actually
move this up to there no big deal
though
this
eh I don't know if you need to Malik
this it's only 19 by
maybe you probably can just leave this
on the
memory might be screwy when you start
running parallel M because this actually
yeah never mind this gets called No Loop
this is not a nit uh but it gets called
serial so actually yeah I don't think
you need to Malik this at all
I do not bite your I do not bite my
thumb at your code sir but I do bite my
okay I'll do like index and size or
something but I get what you
mean oh no because it's a q okay I see
what you did here so
uh yeah cuz when you do breath first
when you do Q instead of a stack it has
to be circular so if you hit the end of
the Q you have to roll it over
capture
count
here if not equals continue and then
unindent all
this this is
like this is deeper than it needs to be
you basically are only allowed to indent
this deep if you're writing uh like a
convolution kernel or something
but this is not actually like seven
layers of logic deep it's
just the conditionals are
good count
Liberties this is the slow function
remember this the low
one you can just write the mem set into
this function so that you don't have to
keep like calculating the sizes and
stuff you can leave it as a function
just make it the fast
one yeah the unindent pattern is very
important probably stylistically it's
probably the biggest thing I've noticed
with your code is
um not using the unindent pattern like
there's actually there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with deeply indented
code the thing that's the only thing is
when you have deeply indented code that
does not need to be deeply invented uh
indented right like you don't need to
make five
functions uh for like a convolution
right in order to like make it less
indented that's just stupid um but when
you have something that can very cleanly
logically be expressed just by like you
know inverting the condition you should
usually do that
particularly for things like guard
checks like up if it's not this then
continue that's like usually the best
case to do it
you might just want to make an inline
bound check inline bound check function
because I've seen this like at least
three different places in the code
right this one doesn't even need to be
like an unindent this can just be like
equal zero and right this is like an and
literally right here
probably when you have a function where
you like reuse an obnoxious constant
like this 10 times you can just put the
thing at the top right like grid like
numb tiles or something total tiles
whatever CU you know I see it here I see
it here I see it
here in fact you literally do it here
you could just move this line up
you also you don't always need theic
stuff
like you don't need to Malik stuff
within a single function in fact you
should pretty much try never to Malik
stuff within a function that's going to
be
running uh you know throughout the whole
game like this is not big enough that
you should need the
Malik oh also yeah prefer cak over Malik
usually but that's not as
big and the thing is I say prefer calic
over Malik even though I believe it's
slower because like you shouldn't never
be using it at runtime if you can avoid
it right like you use you initialize
memory um at the start if you can and
like stuff like this like you get to do
this when you have a board size that's
like 2,000 by 2,000 and you're
overflowing your stack that's about it
t one time kind of mid
actually um
again I mean very small things like you
can make this a local and then you don't
have to redo the check
but this
tiny I'm a little bit sussed out by the
way that you do this
though maybe see people do
this but
uh yeah I'm kind of sketched out by
putting to see people actually do
this hold
I hate
that probably see people do
this I freaking hate that but I wouldn't
be surprised that people do
God ARG is working on your website
awesome
text to the right of games below games
each game is now an iframe okay awesome
yeah
um the main thing is that it has to it
loads it has to like load the games
either on click or like something so it
doesn't like slow the main web page load
down a ton and then on the right side we
can put game instructions I want to put
like contributor like contributions like
people who made the MS or whatever in
like Big Font there yeah that's awesome
that saves me a
well that's dumbb on me for not knowing
this but in my defense I haven't written
C it like in 10 years until
recently write it down
man I mean you're good it's there's
nothing I said that's really important
there other than just like
um just as long as like the page it
doesn't load super slow because it like
tries to load all the M's immediately
when you load the page or something
be
good okay so you don't have a just add
me we'll do
calculate
Liberties
groups check
captures reporting back just finished
implementing puffer VC engine on my
custom gym just got 3x speat up thank
you for your Godly work hey I'm glad it
helps now uh if you go from like python
to C or whatever with puffer VEC you'll
get
100x you can also get 100x and cython
often times just won't have the fun web
demos do be sure to feed the uh feed the
puffer a star if he's been useful to you
puffer subsists on a diet of
it yeah the Stars really
help
captured it's social I I wish I didn't
have to do Twitter honestly it's such a
big distraction but it's it's actually
been the best thing for growth on all
this
okay I see what you did here I don't
hate this this is fine
did you ask anything in the past couple
minutes nothing
now and these meem
copies I don't know when you left the
only major thing I told you was uh that
you probably don't need this Malik
here probably don't need this
day wait did you PR and duro start like
wait did you PR and duro bet do you have
uh something
done all
right you can let me know whether I need
uh coffee or whiskey for the code
Ral you'll be
good it's a lot of
twoos mcode making your brain Rod or is
it all right no it's pretty much
fine I mean it's only complicated cuz
like the logic of go and the rules are
actually kind of intricate like sistic
this is pretty much fine I've had a
couple minor like minor things but I'm
doing pretty good
here yeah this is the Inplay Shuffle I
told you this is
good
uh wait did it work like this
wait was this
count let's
see oh okay this is
fine 700 lines for Enduro there's a lot
of
logic geez
really I'm sorry I didn't expect the m
to be that complicated
Group
Liberty 700 is quite
substantial if it's 700 it actually
needs to be 700 that's uh I mean we'll
see how the the code is if you've
completed a 700 line code project um
that's actually a pretty damn good
progress you've not been doing this for
very
long take you like three to four days
yeah
but I'd be surprised if it's if it's
actually 6700 lines of code that's quite
substantial if there's like if that's
like actual mlogic code I could see the
rendering being a little bit obnoxious
for Enduro
but okay why do we
have several different breath first
searches here this is find Group Liberty
didn't I just see a breath for search up
Liberties Dynamic car position CS well
I'll look at it
I will apologize if I assigned you
something that is harder than I
though it's fun good should
be
Liberty enemy greedy
hard all right so there's a few things I
don't get like I don't know why this is
its own separate this looks pretty
pretty similar to the one
above I guess this is short circuiting
so it like it just
Returns the first Liberty versus
resetting yeah
okay if I see a third breath for search
copy pasted then I'm going to be
concerned enemy greedy
hard for
this is a bit
much few things like this are a bit
why is there even a base case
here when can it ever like not find a
move
here this one sets priority to
move to moves that can capture
t one two three four moves to capture
itot okay so you came up with a greedy
thing I don't know why
there I don't know why it can like ever
fall down to this this is
interesting you made an easy version as
well in
do I hate imag editors these days what
the hell is this
[ __ ] all right I can't apparently you
can't make a joke these days but like
yeah
getting better with it it just needs to
be uh you're getting better with it I've
seen you fixed it in a few places it
just needs to be the default thing you
think you're probably
right I know I've been tired last couple
days I kind of floored myself with the
Half Marathon
yesterday cuz I just I really haven't
been maintaining the running volume to
do a 3our run in the heat up
and I think you just have enemy greedy
easy hardcoded for now which is
fine this mem
copy I might want to stick these into
like a function or
whatever reset state or whatever
calculable
for
Okay I uh Spencer I'll merge this I've
given you some things to fix on this I
think overall pretty darn good um few
small style things few small
potential efficiency things
obviously there's a lot of domain
specifics with go that I'm not positive
on uh so I'm going to merge this I'm
going to do some perf tests I'm going to
show you how to do I think if you're
still here I'm going to show you how to
do the C profile checks that should be
pretty
enlightening I'll give you a minute to
see if you're you're still here but I'm
going to go use a restroom real quick
before I do that and reset be right
okay
wait I know none of this yeah wait we're
going to need
[ __ ] you write down the stuff he says
we're going to need this for every
en take notes I can use for my
EnV it's just general engineering stuff
bet yes he's out yeah okay Spencer I see
you're still here so we're going to do L
merge and Le perf
this is another thousand lines of
contributor code thank you very
much boom th lines of contributor
code isn't that nice how easy it is to
get one of these things
playable Oho
score I think we got to just keep going
until uh until it resets or whatever
right when you play an invalid move it
just skips your turn
Spencer in this version
if I click it like it seems like it
skips my
capture uh when I capture the stones it
lets me like play on those
stones like you saw
that like
look so there's some
bugs Z dead out of some
here all right so I got these Stones
right boom they disappear and I can play
there
and I capture all these I guess and the
game goes on and on and
on wait when you capture the stones do
you take them off of the board cuz I was
able to play clicking manually
right is that a
capture the [ __ ] maybe I just don't
understand how go works but look now
they captured my stones and now we can
both play here again it's like the
infinite
game that's not how it works
what I thought you didn't take the
stones off the board when you capture do
I just have to go learn
go I thought the stones like stayed on
the board
oh well that wait then how does the game
end like nobody can capture what all
right screw me I guess what do I
know what I get for being an arrogant
ass okay both players have to pass
interesting
weird freaking
game okay here's a
client no a perfect test
well enemy doesn't
pass all right we'll have to mess with
some stuff I did not realize what I was
getting myself
into big
deal alphago has similar logic
in
interesting what do you just do like
Rand percent grid size squared or
something making a move can only worsen
your
position
interesting so we do like this yes we
are
agreed then we do free allocated
can we beat Alpha go almost certainly
not that's not the question the question
is can we do something can we make
something that's better than an amateur
go player with like really stupidly
simple methods in like I don't know a
thousand lines of Open Source
is Holy
leaks Max sanitized doesn't show leaks
apparently let me uh stop trolling with
this stream
layout move
myself back over
here back over here
yeah solid
SPS well done there
brother this one is very very bad this
one is like legitimately very bad this
one is uh you got a legit inprocess like
mem right
I only get
750k though maybe this processor is old
solid what do we think about this
instead of cic
look at that where did all of the uh the
mem leaks
and you forgot to
free the log
buffer
really oh it's free log
all right that might have even got you a
little bit more perf it was 750 before I
think yeah so I even got you a little
bit more perf with that and fix the
leaks just a little bit could just be
noise to be
they've got like a border around the
cells
right just from that
Malik well one that was a giant memory
leak but yeah also don't be maling stuff
inside of program execution unless you
absolutely have
to like there's literally no reason to
put it on the Heap
unless you're trying to handle go boards
that like you know you're doing some
crazy thing where you're like I want any
size go I want go to be able to be
played on a 2000 x2000 board then you
just don't need
enough oh yeah I promised you profiling
didn't
I let's do that
so let me find the post
this yeah so I've got this build fast
option right and make this compile with
PG like
okay you can see performance took a
little hit from the profiler but we
don't
care and see that there's some
files then we just G
profile
go on.
out text
see is real easy when you have a couple
little tools isn't
it don't count your liberators before
they
hatch let me see if you're doing
anything ridiculous
let's make sure it's not reset I don't
think it's the
reset we'll just double
though does this call
anything no it doesn't
gets called a lot
though kind of
what's this temp board
States so what we can just do
like end
you can double check that but I think
that that's what you want to do
well there you go I just got you a
little bit more perf
this here
[Music]
it where does it get called
from it only gets called in these two
places right
so
uh while is dangerous
no I mean it depends what you mean by
dangerous how do you propose to to
implement
um like a graph
that's probably the biggest one I can
see right
now
uh oh this is a break not a wait is this
a break or
continue no it's a continue
dang
dang do you
well there's one more I can think of
whoops
one more that I can potentially think of
but it's speculative
I can't tell so I'm going to leave it
the way that you had it
uh 800k ain't
bad and that's with
uh
count
Liberties this has got to be cashed or
something I'm
sure important thing is now you know
where this is I gave you a little bit of
optimization here but you know now
exactly where you need to most likely
just start caching
stuff let me make sure I didn't break
anything
good gives you capture counts as well
which is kind of
okay that is
pushed we've now
gotten Connect 4 and go into reasonable
States I would
say um I wanted to train a policy for
Connect 4 and to do a few other things
since I think you're not home yet and I
can chat with you on uh yeah I can chat
with you on stuff specifics later today
if you're around
um
cool I'm trying to think what to
do probably Quick Connect 4 policy do a
quick round of checks on X and Discord
make sure I'm not missing
anything and then we'll keep going won't
be home till later yeah no
thanks for review yeah of course thank
you for the pr
and cool just a bunch of random
engagement looking
good what about
Discord anybody asking for stuff
maybe cap
interesting what is ml
chat I don't know random group chat
all right well let's do the Connect 4
thing real quick cuz that's
easy
box hey that guy yeah we can do we can
add that thing
it's do I just PR this to the hold
on hopefully this doesn't break
the puffer tank PRS are kind of
obnoxious because they're not actually
like in the docker I'll do that in a sec
hold
on
uher box
this that's solid code contributions
right
there what do we think the odds are that
we just solved the Connect 4 with
um policy got a sign off for now ping
you later talk about policies to train
board board sizes yep sounds good let me
know when you're around see
y thanks for the pr
this is a tiny little
Network it's not running very fast at
the moment because
um well it's running like half the speed
it should be because the batch size is
too small let's just see if this
it I'm worried that there's still going
to be deficiencies in the opponent that
it's exploiting but but we'll
here that' be
interesting it takes it longer to figure
how to beat this
interesting so it's better than the buil
10 but it's
not it has like a 70% win
rate I mean that's probably just model
capacity though
whatever me this is a Tiny
Network it's kind of interesting that it
does this well with this number of
parameters wouldn't it be funny if a
6,000 parameter network is like better
connect four than I am
give it a recurrent
policy let's see what happens in the
meantime I will go grab the wyb
parameter
land
pyo interesting that the bigger model
has not done any
better still at
70% maybe that's what you draw maybe
that's the draw rate
well this is going to be
spammy we probably want to load this
right
oops okay so this should
be the new
it excuse
me why doesn't this show me
winning oh it just there's like you have
to press a button at the end when you
win that's
I'm trying to figure out how good the
bot is it's not very good right it like
let me
lot still needs updates I
think I mean
why can I like construct this in a
principled
way there's something weird about this
isn't
there yeah there's something weird about
this it doesn't block if you have two
ways to win but if it looks too it
shouldn't let me get two ways to win
needs more than three steps to stop that
does it oh is it three or
four right
now I mean I see it has
there that
five so why did it just go oh cuz it
just won because I'm stupid
so it looks at its move and then your
move and then its move I
guess well we should be able to beat
this then like 100% right
if that's all it
does let me see if we can beat
it but too
slow we should be able to beat the
current version though right
70 there is an opening it was doing that
sets up a trap
reliably can't remember changing
anything well that's weird because I
only get seven
with this one and it takes longer as
well
didn't even change anything yet it's a
tiny policy
thanks for review yeah of course I had
on there's a stream portion you can
watch VOD 4 as
well thank you for
80 I mean this network is like
pathetically
parameters that really not
matter or
Worse unless it just takes
longer no this looks worse
high uh it doesn't look to be diverging
substantially from that though we'll see
if that was the issue
this is making it learn slower let's see
if it learns any better
um
that just learns way too
million no easily discoverable
bugs progress
it's a little better isn't
it RL not like the rest of
ml all right I just got it from uh 70 to
90 % win rate in about 20
minutes I did batch size and stuff as
well a little more than that you
entropy and we can always just run a
sweep on it at this point because it's
doing well
enough well no it was in this case it
was the larger batch size larger batch
size is equals more stable training
updates in fact we can make it even much
larger if this entropy doesn't just fix
it it doesn't look like it
did
see it's about the
same 928
why don't we do a double it again
65 and
two
this he
dubs we got Connect 4 gaming in
here training Connect 4 on stupidly
small Network 1.2 million
bot check if it learned same opening
trap sure
thing let me see if this does any better
and then we'll uh we'll do a track run
exploitable relatively
easily I mean it's just like n look
ahead
4 100 million Connect 4 in 90 seconds
sounds good to
me it will play more Connect 4 than
anybody has ever played in 90
seconds right nobody's played that much
Connect
we'll see whether this breaks the 90
from before I think it
should really satisfying contributing to
the project I hope so hope you're feel
like you're learning some cool stuff as
well there you go little less sample
efficient but um
is it going to get stuck
I'm sure we'll be able to just bu hyper
pram sweep we'll probably solve it in
fact if you have like even a decent s
GPU I can uh I'll let you do the hyper
Prem sweep and you can submit the solve
model if you
want I can show you how to set that
stuff
up I got to buy more machines for the
cluster so I can get more contributors
on
so
oops Huffer
lib it's a clean reward curve look at
that look how clean that
is reinforcement learning does not like
that does not like to produce clean
reward
curves unless you make things really
really
fast off to bed now though see you
around thank you
correctly how you
have money for so many
machines because if I wanted to buy even
one node um for like language model
learning like 8X 8x h00 Bock or whatever
would be like 200 Grand uh the whole
puffer cluster is like 30 grand for
eight of
winning why does this not look like it's
winning
okay maybe it's not loading correctly
hold on
32 128 and
7 all right
looks like the policy is just bugged I
mean not the policy the
uh let's see the games are all
different not like exploiting RNG or
something stupid yeah look it just
blocked
it
policy why did it reset there I feel
like I'm just not seeing it complete
are you smarter than a 6,000 parameter
neural network is what this is going to
[Music]
be let's see why this is not occurring
cuz here it just gets kicked it gets its
ass kicked
right so we're not loading it
correctly
on we still loading it
wrong
yep
okay let me just make absolutely sure
because it's going to be really obno
just
folks trying to figure out why this
network is not loading because I have it
in eval here I can
see um I can see that it's correct when
I run it with python it's not loading
correctly into C I
believe be fair this is
not as thoroughly tested
right how many weights have we got here
default copy and
observations then we have actions
right so this looks reasonable to
[Music]
me
H do I need to check peret
I don't think I had any errors in
here i' be surprised but guess it's
possible so what's this we get a
network num
agents input
dim and code
go input to
Hidden a
r did I miss a or something
stupid ISS encoder decoder and value is
all they're in that
actions now there's one re in here it's
literally just like linear re
good lift heavy
good we're going to see what I can bench
after this
there any custom code well I'm loading
this [ __ ] into C
so yeah there's a lot of stuff that can
go
wrong hold on
maybe how's this
defined in the
network n it's default as far as I know
well it's not you can clearly tell the
policy when loaded into C is nowhere
near as good as the
policy uh when I load it from
python something screwy
show
you
you're
right think you are loading the pong
weights am I actually loading the
freaking pong
weights I swear if I'm loading the
WS brainless idiot thank
you [ __ ]
catch here we'll get your policy online
Jake thanks for coming back to save me
that
policy Hong played Connect 4 yeah that
doesn't work so
well uh it does seem like the uh the
opponent policy is sometimes just screws
up in Dumb Ways though like it seems
like you only have one way to win and it
misses
and press shift
whenever okay so let's see what it does
it could play either side oh wait did
you randomize what side it plays
I mean we should probably what we should
do is we should
randomize at any depth is the
same all right it seems like there might
still be some small tweaks to make here
but this is way better
okay so here it made this
move it'll block me here
open oh
didn't you added this as a did you add
this as a book opening I
think yeah I see cuz it prevents it from
doing like the
cheese yeah yeah yeah okay so the book
open prevents the cheese I
see but you can still do it later on in
the game right like if I just
cheese oh wait it let
me why let me do
that so really you need to go like one
additional depth
three I changed that to three or
whatever
how sure are we that this depth search
thing is implemented right
he's right that it kills mpf though it's
going to need
like well we'll have to do some serious
stuff to get it to be
faster you can see it's it went from 1.1
mil down to
300K 70% time bottleneck on
N longer episodes only 12
I mean still though we're at 80% win
rate against this thing with a 6,000
parameter
I mean what do we think the odds are
that there's some cheese that like
there's some edge cases that the
algorithm isn't catching even at this
depth
because like 50 million steps 6,000
parameter model close on 90%
act do star the puffer folks starting
the repo helps me out a
ton I mean okay if it keeps this level
of perf we only
lost like 2
3% back from well the thing is
like if it's more than two or three look
ahead it's not really a cheese anymore
right but like it's kind of sus that
um the m is slower but it doesn't seem
to actually be any
perfectly yeah but you R do you random
it looks like you randomized the start
order right
I mean regardless this is yeah we're
matching the accuracy of the previous
one so I'm not actually sure if this Max
algorithm is
doing like it doesn't seem like it made
the game any
harder we're within like 1% of where we
were
before right
unless we just train some like 6,000
parameter God policy
h oh there's an easy way to check that
you turn it up to like five or something
it'll still be fast enough for you to
play it it should just destroy
you but yeah we're at a look at that 94
literally we finished exactly where we
did before the end was just
compare play with this depth against old
policy we can
try but uh let me
yeah look at these the curves are like
the
same oh the episode length is one off
right that's kind of
interesting it's one longer episode
length with the new one so there is a
difference that's an appreciable
difference maybe we trained maybe we
just trained a god policy you know maybe
maybe this is just the god
policy for
um let's see if this thing ever like
wins to [ __ ] anymore
copy okay so here
is the policy
block why did it do that did you just
see that it went here and it gave it a
free win one step ahead on the
diagonal I think the dep policy is
bugged like it's probably better but I
think that their Edge case is not
getting caught like look it just gave it
a win
yeah scripted AI I think scripted AI
bugged
[Music]
better than
before but still
bugged most likely you just got like a
one line or something in the max
function that you got to
fix second win was understandable here
I'll slow it
down I mean it's a deterministic
algorithm right so here you go look um
red should not go in the second position
here
it has
three it doesn't have
win so right the only win I
see is if red does not
go oh it's yeah I see it I see it yeah
it's got okay you're
right no I understood the first game it
had two diagonal
wins let's see if I mean you only need
to have one [ __ ] game to know it's
bugged
there why did it just go
here red just went here
why now it wins now blue wins
right red should not have gone here
this looks like an
exploit and then blue just went
here and red just went
here you figured it
out you found bug
oh you're
right [ __ ]
there okay so this is like the it plays
this game a lot
there
okay where's Red go so red goes
there why would red just go
there why did Red just give it this win
right am I missing it or is this or is
this an error red just went right here
same logic
where so if blue goes
here then red goes here and you're fine
aren't
you if red doesn't go Blue can go and
then take the drag
hell I guess I'm dumber than a 6,000
parameter policy you're right
bust is this thing [ __ ] 200 IQ or is
it dumb I can't
tell step right up folks see if you're
if you're smarter than a 6,000 parameter
neural
network can't see
oh it's right dude it's freaking right
hold
on I think it's
right
so [ __ ] hell so if it goes
here dude this thing is right what the
hell
so I mean this is your scripted thing
not the neural network so obviously it's
right but it's so hard to read for a
human so if I go here no if it goes
here okay then I go
here and then it gets stuck because uh
it has to go here or I win but it also
go has to go here or I win so three
moves ahead I have
so it's smart
I
think it shouldn't assume you can see it
though yeah you need to change it so
that
um you need to change it so that it
blocks uh it blocks like the nearest
one it needs to block like the if there
are wind consons
it needs to block immediate wind
con I know you got to go to sleep it's
only 5:30 here 5:20 do you want me to
mess with it for a little bit
would improve performance yeah fire away
okay you get some sleep I'm going to
take a couple minutes to reset here and
then uh I'm going to just see if I can
make a couple tweaks to your thing real
quick so it it's more sensible and I'm
not going to go crazy with it um but
hopefully I get somewhere with that and
we'll see uh it's kind of crazy that I
can still beat this thing though like I
can literally beat it without seeing
it all
right I'll be right back folks get some
sleep Jake awesome uh contribution thank
you for
that I'll polish it up and see if I get
a nice demo on uh online for tomorrow be
right
out the goal here is to fix the
algorithm so it actually plays locally
well as well as uh min
max and then we'll train the neur versus
that and uh the goal is that we have
like
a strong 6,000 parameter model so we can
ask are you smarter than a 6,000
parameter neural network and the answer
is probably
no okay so let's see what this thing is
um
so it just goes through and it computes
this
search for every possible
play it computes for every possible
play this value
see so how do you implement this this is
just like a way of breaking ties right
heuristic I don't know what's this max
value what's
one I'm confused how this works
negative wi
okay so this is random for anything that
you can't this is the this depth equals
z is actually the leaf nodes
it's probably some form of discounting
right
way it's very simple algorithm I haven't
looked at this type of thing in a
while I'm trying to think if we want
like a multiplicative or an additive or
what we we want
here I mean fundamentally this is
like focus on blocking
okay so it blocks here and then it loses
that's
fine block
here blocks there and then loses
here I think I might have done it I
think it's just literally was just
here you block
here plays
here well this was weird
right why did it do
that it didn't block a victory here did
it
what did
it does anybody see it it played here
and then the red played here is there
any reason for
that it's supposed to
somehow I don't think so
played
here no I don't think
so I think it's screwed up and I can't
win I'm what I'm trying to do right now
for reference is I have this search
based bot uh but it's very unintuitive
because if it sees that you can win like
three moves ahead it'll basically just
give up and stop trying um so I'm trying
to make it so that even if it sees you
can win three moves ahead it's still
going to try to take uh it's not going
to it's going to try to like make you
actually have to win in three
I think we got to change the way that
this
works if we change it to like Max
mean or
[Music]
something I got to love when you know
something that's pretty basic like seven
years ago is suddenly
hard what do you want to do here do you
want to count
I hate recursive
logic I really
do should it be like a Max mean or
something e
okay so this is going to
be
equals so we're basically we're trying
to just sum up
the number of cases in which they win
which I don't actually know if that's a
good idea hey thank you
FL was
it best
column let's just do
int
S
zero we go through the columns if it's
invalid we
continue play
this oops
let's do float best
value best
value
there we
value there we go now we know the best
go now we know the best
value ties
then
best
tie yeah I'm always at
good do I see
what do you see
it if you see it you see it if you don't
you don't
there's a cool thing to
see I ruin it if I tell you
confusing I'm basically I'm trying to
figure out if it's looking at the board
if it's seeing it correctly
things okay so what's it say
here it
says that I should go there
why did it go
there oh
what it says if you go in the third
slot it has
okay
so say I go like this right
wait so
why why did it do that
then I'm probably printing this at the
wrong spot right
values okay I think I understand
so the value I'm Computing is the number
of games where if I go in that cell the
opponent wins
you we'll see if the human of in we'll
see if the human of uh of your
intelligence is beaten by a 6,000
parameter Network or
interestingly it
says
uhhuh
nose maybe this is
better I might actually have it better
now that's going to always be a
three we don't care about that so I go
here and then hold on obnoxiously you
actually kind of have to play this thing
well
oh I think I lose don't
I it doesn't make a move
move
Bizarro oh because it can't move at the
top is
uh I hate to break it to you bet but uh
the 6,000 parameter neural network might
be
smarter it's okay it's better than me
blocks that as
well in
it let me think does the thing I'm doing
even make sense you count the number of
games
does it take its win
now let's see
win
good so is this better
well let's see can I actually beat it or
actually can this bot beat
it it's even
interesting H it takes its win at the
top now
I think I might have made a much
stronger
block yeah why the hell did it not block
that's bizarre
oh because you're not counting this
correctly
dummy you're not counting this
okay
but one
yeah the day kind of got away from me
today but there's uh I think I got
this all this
so let's do
this let's do
right let's make sure I don't mess this
up
oh wait it doesn't recompile Okay so
this is
62 I
[ __ ]
huh that's
harder we'll give it this
run and then uh we'll
I don't know if I have this implemented
completely
correctly but
um the goal was to
count like if I play this move you count
like the number of times that well first
of all you see if the opponent can win
immediately that gets assigned to very
high value and then you it's essentially
discounting it's like
discounting it's a discounted count of
the number of games in which the
opponent wins it's like Max mean with
aggressive discounting I
guess I don't know maybe it also it just
gets the same win rate versus this I
don't
know looks likely at this point it's got
40 million steps to get a 10 10ish per
more Act
episode length is longer actually that's
true that's probably a good sign
no it's playing against the scripted
bot but I I don't know if I made the
scripted bot better we'll see I think I
might
have I mean the episodes are
substantially longer
and it looks like the policy goes it
dropped from like 93% accuracy in 100
Mil to
88 uh 90 let's call it so that's like a
stronger
model that's a stronger model
right it's faster as well training is a
bit
faster I didn't even full optimize it
and let me go grab the model I'm going
to tr I'm going to test this and this
will be the last thing I do
today actually let's check train curve
as well just so we see the
difference oh yeah look at that you
see return takes longer it doesn't get
quite as well and the episode length
there a better
model trained against stronger opponent
I bet our model is better too
says yeah okay so now it shows me that
the
score it's about 0. n which is what we
thought is
correct it's doing nice things
all right let's see if I can beat this I
doubt I can beat it I actually doubt
that I can beat this in like one try if
I'm not like being super careful with
yeah okay this is a pretty strong
scripted bot
now it feels
yeah and let's see now let's let the
model
play I just pause it so we can see what
it's doing
bad well it's not taking moves which is
probably bad
no red is just not taking
moves we have fix that
um yeah but red is not there's a there's
a glitch with red where it doesn't take
moves at the top
sometimes we'll figure it out
but uh that's that's enough for the time
being um I got it my schedule's gotten
pushed too late so I'm going to go get
my exercise in I'm going to get
food um you're free to look at
it they're probably just some minor
tweaks I think it is better it's just
that there's a
bug
website website's the old
website Link in DM I don't know why this
isn't doing
this looks
solid the games take longer to load hold
on because like if I click here it's
pretty much instant right it's like
instant load even for the complicated
cached should be instant
okay
think asked him to make several
okay yeah I'm trying to think cuz like
this keeps it
he doesn't think perf is decreased okay
most people watching on Twitch no not
really uh the people who like to chat a
lot go on Twitch cuz like YouTube and uh
X sometimes eat your
messages we have uh I think the majority
are YouTube actually but twitch is the
best for messages and then X is like
yeah if you're just on
X um this is cool
yeah I'm trying to think
like I think we can jam this I think
this is
good I'm going to wonder about stuff
like full screen and whatnot and like
other controls that this might mess up
we'll
see but yeah they okay they come out as
an ey frame
ready for commit if you
want I mean I'm happy to just merge I
can like hard merge now um I'm trying to
think so basically the thing I wasn't
sure about is whether I want those if
frames all on the main page or not like
cuz I like having this like gallery of
lots of M's that you can click on
it's probably best the way that he has
it
frankly let me see this
again yeah cuz it's on the main page
like this right with this like local
X okay yeah I like
it
sweet yeah go I'm going to want to play
with it a little bit and see if I uh if
I like it but I I like I think
yeah okay because it keeps you on the
main
page you don't actually have to go load
a different
page push now yeah are you in voice with
him what's what's up with this
okay
cool I can hop in there in a bit I got a
one or two things to do and then I'll
jump in
there PR here
solid just go work
out
okay I'll do that
um oh I guess you're just dming him okay
cool well I mean if he gets invoic at
some point I'll like to thank him for
this this is like this is pretty nice um
and I think we'll probably be able to
optimize some stuff as well cuz like a
lot of the stuff in the resources folder
is shared as
well so probably if like there's one
build we cannot package everything into
Wasa multiple times or
whatever all right when I get to the gym
I'll do that I got to do a couple quick
things first well thanks folks uh one
last thing so we'll be back with this
tomorrow as well um lots of Dev here if
you want to support
for free just star the repository helps
us out a ton you know feed the puff for
a
star the growth on this has been
absolutely great and uh really just have
to keep it up helps me keep doing this
stuff closing on
1200 you can also follow my X it is
all reinforcement
learning I'll link that as
well most of my stuff stuff including
like how to get into RL and like more
technical like Cutting Edge researches
on